[Music]
i like this one because i know nick's
gonna lose his [ __ ] hearing this i'm
gonna be so chill a teacher in an
english village
high school was recently fired for not
protecting a student being savagely
beaten by a gang in the classroom
what he got fired for for not so the
teacher just watched
a kid
beat up another kid a game a gang he
[ __ ] up a kid a gang of kids he
watched a gang jump a kid in his class
and he just froze up
and his reasoning for that is that he
didn't have the training he was never
trained is it illegal to be a [ __ ]
though because that's the question right
is it should it be illegal to be afraid
it might be great first of all
yeah what grade right great what great
great if it's a bunch of seniors you
said yeah it's high school yeah okay
okay
hey check this out high school is your
biggest [ __ ]
what if
it's a
polynesian high school see polynesian
high school i'm not getting involved at
all dude let me let me tell you a junior
high story
i went to carmeneta junior high in
cerritos i went to tesla okay so we're
pretty much related
and uh one of my homies in seventh grade
he was on the other side of the
classroom with social studies
and you know it's that era where like
any of your homies jump in you gotta go
you jump in you gotta get one right
him and this other dude
they start getting into it that dude
starts beating his ass
i look over and i'm like oh [ __ ]
and then the teacher comes to separate
them the other kid who's samoan so he's
six two yeah grabs the teacher by the
head launches the the female teacher
across the classroom
i was like if the teacher can't handle
this student should be jumping
so i just stayed there and i'm like yeah
this is crazy i don't know if teachers
should step in it depends on the
situation look teacher got [ __ ]
launched across the room yeah yeah yeah
but if it was a gang of third graders
man this teacher is a little [ __ ] dude
[ __ ]
in high school and what if it's like two
different gang members it was like two
games going like i'm gonna jump in front
of the middle of a gang fight yeah i
like how he was like i'm not trained so
he's like oh i don't know jujitsu like
[ __ ] i wish i took take one don't
[ __ ] lie
if it was just like a bully picking on a
kid you'd get get involved cause it's
also if it is a gang related thing
then you take that home with you right
imagine 18th street versus someone else
18th street's gonna go to your house oh
you're done you know so that's also i
don't know what the gangs are in the
[ __ ] crumpets in the tea land
dog is it actually
gang related like a cup of tea it's it's
it's kind of unclear because maybe it's
a br it's since it's in uh england it
could be a british tournament a gang is
like a flock there's an actual numbers
social oh yeah yeah but it it might be
like i think it's like six or seven
dudes pounding because in l.a
look the gangs will go to your house man
it's not the teacher's job to play
security they [ __ ] went there to
teach algebra not to [ __ ] up kids if
it's six guys beating up one person yeah
what's the one teacher going to do the
rocks
unless you're a big giant dude but then
again it's like you got to get your two
chalkboard erasers
yeah or fire extinguishers
just smoke grenades
what if the teacher like didn't like the
kid getting oh just messed up
he's like oh no i told you johnny we all
don't like your ass i told you he said
i'm here to educate about justice today
he's like damn you keep talking [ __ ] i
told you keep talking [ __ ] people [ __ ]
you honestly honestly johnny could be an
[ __ ] bro if six dudes want to kick
his ass maybe he deserves it exactly
we don't know we don't know the context
all right here's a little bit here's a
little bit more the teachers might think
you can get awesome
slightly more context from the teacher
on his side of things he's free bro he's
good to go so mr murphy definitely froze
up and he was sorry that he did that
it's just his instinct was that he
didn't know what to do because he wasn't
trained yeah but no training's gonna
help you with that part of what might
have contributed to that hesitation
is that a while back he was receiving
threats
for like i guess um it said another
people was making threats to him with a
broken glass and fires and a fire
extinguisher a month or so prior so it
might have made an impact on his like
fear to like get involved because
they've already threatened him in the
past for sure um
in the states i don't know what it's
like out there but if the teachers get
caught
handling a student a certain way they
could get [ __ ] sued and america you
can't do that they used to beat the [ __ ]
out of kids in america but not anymore
no yeah now the teacher's still the
kid's [ __ ] up he's scared right he
also hasn't made that switch like you
know you get threatened enough you gotta
flip that switch like i don't give a
[ __ ] no more do you think he had made a
switch but your military i heard other
friends in the military that said they
were in war and guys on their squad were
hella scared in war they wouldn't even
shoot that's normal yeah that's normal
yeah people freeze all the time man and
this friendly fire [ __ ] get shot in
the butt by your own homie like we shoot
people shooting at us and he's like dude
we're shooting like i'm looking at other
dudes they're just not shooting i'm like
hey you better start shooting like
they're shooting at us yeah it's
normally just freezing that's regular
how do you know that you have [ __ ] made
platoon buddies you went through [ __ ]
camp until you get to war yeah you don't
you just don't know i mean you could see
signs
some people are just more timid what do
you feel like was the average percentage
potential i know we're just making
enough statistics
bar has statistics of that like out of
10 people the punk ass weak ass fools
statistic oh what do you do you just
yell at him i feel like it's like
probably broken up into thirds it's
probably like a third of 30
yeah it's probably a third of people
that are crazy as [ __ ] yeah and you're
like and then oh you just joined for an
excuse to kill someone yeah yeah and
there's probably 30 no maybe maybe 60
and 20 and 20. okay 60 people are just
regular you push me enough yeah we
figured it out i gotta like we gotta
like do something and there's the other
20 that are like on the other side
that's just gonna get scared so 20
extreme they're just trying to shoot
people because they get guns they're in
the military because they want to kill
people and then 20 they'll freeze up and
that's 60 are actually maybe like a good
movie is like uh like jarhead
with jake gyllenhaal like his buddy uh i
don't forgot his name but he was an
eight-mile chatter bob like he hit her
he couldn't wait to kill somebody right
he got to iraq he was happy he was like
[ __ ] yeah i'm gonna shoot these people
and then most people are like jake
gyllenhaal like oh [ __ ] what are we
doing here are we really doing good i
don't really know [ __ ] i'm out here you
know and there's other people that are
just like [ __ ] ptsd oh [ __ ] i need to
get the [ __ ] you know just like brains
malfunction who do you guys think you
would be in war
i'm probably the bottom tier of the
sixty percent
yeah i mean you're not quite tall i'm
like in the hundred i'm in like the
thirty nine to forty six probably yeah i
think i think that's all i think it's
spot-on
i would not wanna be there i would not
wanna be there but push come to shove
like they start [ __ ] we're gonna have to
start shooting and each level is a new
challenge like our buddy don right who's
a
special operations marine he went first
over there as infantrymen and you're
rolling deep you need you call in tanks
you could do whatever right so that's a
different feeling than when you went
special operations jumping out of a
[ __ ] airplane behind enemy lines
people don't even know that you're there
no support only [ __ ] 10 of these guys
the first firefight he got into he was
like oh [ __ ] this is different and then
the fire fight is different from getting
when you're with your platoon yeah
because you have zero you have zero
support you
[ __ ] that the only you only have
you only have maybe three days worth of
food on you right and so if the fire
fight turns into seven days now what
happens if your airplane can't come get
you until 14 days then exactly you got
to figure it out think about i think
about this [ __ ] i've placed my brother
all the time but like us going away like
anthony i swear to [ __ ] god i'm gonna
go around the corner you better be sure
if you don't [ __ ] shoot yeah it would
be so bad bro
because i'm going around the corner
seriously look at my eye for now because
we're doing this like yeah and i'm back
why aren't you saying this to nick i'm
like why are you looking at me like you
know
i'm just trying to go to college with
this man i can't afford college roll
over there when i do that [ __ ] you
better start yeah okay okay okay we go
our lives are [ __ ] over we should
i'll get mad at you why are you so brave
i mean are your conversations going like
that like for sure i'm going around this
[ __ ] corner someone better [ __ ]
cover yeah how does communication work
when everybody's like yelling at the
same time so the guy so like what we
just did
actually you have leaders right guys
i've been through it so don's boss he
says when he first comes his first fire
fight don was kind of [ __ ] bricks
and then his his boss was just smoking a
cigarette just he was like the bullets
he's that guy
john's boss is like i need a light
yeah it's like those vietnam movies you
know like when they're there the [ __ ]
commander's just like
they're so used to it he's like see that
[ __ ] yeah you're like so this is nothing
ladies you we've all i mean we i've
heard you know you heard gun go off in
the party we [ __ ] yeah we've run the
[ __ ] everyone down one shot yeah you're
going i always feel like i got shot i
know you're like
i get shot you [ __ ] i popped the
truck get in there
i'm going back and forth
toby when it's over just close it dude
one time one time i was at a party in
west covina and then uh we thought we
heard a gunshot so everybody ducked and
like ran but what it actually was was it
it was the sound of a guy who picked up
a big ass rock and smashed it on another
dude's face oh my god that's how loud it
was that's how loud that [ __ ] was and he
broke he busted this guy's whole face
did he die i don't know where's your
[ __ ] ram
all i remember was i looked
while on the way out like we everyone
still thought it was guns so we everyone
started leaving the party and i saw the
rock and it was on the ground covered in
blood and ants
oh my god was that like nasty it was
like [ __ ] damn ants are fast and the
dude the dude just on the ground like
this i don't like dude that wasn't even
a gunshot fire
who knew that a rock to the face makes
the exact same wave file
it's good adr huh
you